Tomer Cohen, thank you for joining me
on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
I'm great.
How are you, Michael?
Fantastic.
So, you're calling me from Be'er Sheva
next to Ben-Gurion University.
And while you're finishing your undergraduate degree,
it doesn't do justice that title
to what you are actually been doing
in Israel with Tech2Peace
and dealing with one of the most extraordinary
conflicts in history.
Actually, a five thousand year conflict
and making it very relevant to 2020,
bringing technology and peace
into the same equation.
And I am very excited to spend the next
20 minutes or so talking to you about this conflict
but specifically in the context
of how can we leverage technology
and commonalities and similarities
to bridge some deeper rooted conflict.
So, Tomer, take us away.
Tell me a little bit about yourself
and what is Tech2Peace?
So basically, my name is Tomer Cohen.
I'm originally from Jerusalem.
So I'm 27 years old,
actually about to finish
my bachelor's degree
in geography and political science.
Nothing to do with technology so far,
even though in the Army I served
as a finder in a special unit.
But actually the combines between I-Tech
the technology and actually combat world.
So it was very
it was the first very strong moment
of the I-tech in my life in general.
In my first year in my bachelor's degree,
I actually established with
two other founders Tech2Peace.
The Tech2Peace, what we basically do
is to connect between young adults
from Palestine and Israel
between ages 20 to 26.
But two things.
The first thing basically is about
learning technology.
Like if it's programming
or mobile AI development
or AI for programmers and et cetera.
Every participant for two week long seminar
actually dedicated a lot of the time
to study this subject
and actually to build
it's own or his own project.
In addition to very intensive
and very unique dialogue workshops.
That actually my partner is Abeer
which is from East Jerusalem
and Uri from Haifa.
We are actually doing it there.
We speak about everything,
about our personal experiences,
about the history like Nakba
and the Yom Ha'atzmaut Independence Day
and all those issues in two week long seminar.
And actually,
because what we're trying to do is
to build new partnerships,
new friendships and partnerships
that can go for the long term.
Amazing.
So just a little bit of context,
because a lot of the viewers are from,
you know, from California,
not everybody is aware of of the of the
deepness and the complexity
of this conflict.
And I won't be able to do justice
in the 10 second brief.
But it essentially talks about
the Middle East conflict,
the Israeli-Palestinian conflict.
It's much more than just territory.
It's more than just culture.
It's about history.
It's about deep-rooted beliefs.
It's about generations of hatred that have
that have erupted to where we are today
and then unresolved conflicts
that basically the whole world is
trying to help out or not help
in one way or another.
And so, give me a little bit of
what is this problem?
So it's two weeks
where they would come together.
What have you noticed?
And actually, I want to go back to
how it started, because that's a fascinating story
that you started telling me before.
So basically about how it started
and what we basically
actually do every day at Tech2Peace.
So basically two years ago I met
the two other co-founders
Abeer, as I said,
which is from East Jerusalem
and Uri, he's from Haifa originally.
And they actually told me about the work
we actually was running an organization
we called the [--]
Some Israelis maybe know this organization,
but this is another informal organization
which actually combine between Palestinian
like we connect the Palestinians and Israelis.
A full dialogue.
Just to meet, being friends
and actually make, you know,
the most significant connections.
And they did it for almost 10 years.
And like more than 450% in Israel
is actually meant for this program.
[--]
And once I from a moment two years ago,
I was asking them,
"Abeer, Uri, what do you think?
How can we actually create bigger impact?
How can we actually do something?
Yeah, exactly.
How can we actually,
Because it's amazing.
Palestinians and Israelis meet.
But in order to actually try
and do something very significant
with the future of this region,
maybe let's try other methods
And Uri told me that
he  worked for many years.
He's a project manager
in the I-tech industry in Israel.
And I was about just finished
my role in one of the like I think
two Asian companies.
The Israelis actually likes
doing summer camps,
like I-tech in Israel.
And we thought, Okay,
let's maybe try and do something else.
Let's maybe try to do
dialogue seminars like dialogue camps let's say.
We've I-tech in the same time
That actually the participants
will get that vantage to get better future
and some practical over life, basically.
And the reason that we started with this
model, basically, it's because
of two main challenges.
You basically you and the
audience should know about.
First of all, as you can guess,
many of the people who already go
to dialogue, a camp style of seminars
between Palestinian and Israelis,
those are the same convince people.
Yeah.
Like Israelis home mainly from Tel Aviv
and the Palestinians mainly from Ramallah
on the west part of Ramallah.
And some other very specific places.
But most of the people that actually
go and meet, it's the Palestines
And so we thought,
How can we bring new people,
new people from the periphery of Israel,
from the periphery of Palestine,
from refugee camps,
from like Bedouins, from the [--]
How can we bring someone from Ashdod,
from Middle East and Europe and places that
are a bit far from Tel Aviv from the center.
And then we thought about,
let's try and bring them something,
but actually we can use something,
that all the participants
we get out of the benefit of the doubt.
All right.
Basically.
And the second reason
that we established Tech2Peace.
The second challenge which you
wanted to tackle, basically
it was that in many peace camps
and in many other seminars
we basically many times, not always,
but many times there's no continuity.
Right.
And if the Palestinians and the Israelis
basically act like it's very significant
moments and we became really good friends.
Probably once the seminar is over
or the camp is over,
the Palestinians go to their home.
The Israelis go to their homes
and there is no continuity.
There's no threat.
Is it possible to to create continuity
in a matter of a two week program?
Basically, yes, because we sleep together,
we eat together at night.
We actually shared the most
intimate and the most the
personal stories with one another.
We're having fun with one another.
And in those moments of
after we finish the program
around nine or 10PM
those are the moments
where the friendship actually created.
And this is actually what we're trying
to achieve besides all the
very intense survey reasons.
And this is what we do in the seminars.
But other things that you and the audience
actually should know about Tech2Peace.
That once the seminar is over.
All the participants become
automatically alumni of Tech2Peace.
And they start the alumni program,
which means before the coronaviruses,
they give you like every one or two months
actually meeting with experts,
if it's from Google,
fron Microsoft,
sometimes from MIT,
from other places.
In order to give them the additional
value of after the seminar.
Yeah.
And sometimes also, of course,
also dialogue to  get in-depth into the issues
that actually talked during the seminar.
And also between the 90 alumni of Tech2Peace
that we have so far,
17 of them actually work
on cross-border startups together.
This just started in a couple of months ago
to work on cross-border startups
with our amazing partners from Boston.
It's got a 50-50 startups.
It's a new startup incubator.
So it's very exciting.
Wow.
So at the end then,
how many people went through this?
How many of these two week programs
have you done so far?
Since the inception of this.
So the first seminar took place in 2018.
In Yeruham, down south
in very isolated small town.
With actually Michael Biton
who is now in the government
[--]
he actually was the mayor of the city,
in a small town,
and he was very  advocated in order
to let us do the seminars in his town.
And after the pilot seminar we were surprised
because no one think
with actually what is the connection
Between I-tech and dialogue?
But afterwards,  it actually it works.
We did other two seminars
in the summer of 2019.
And in this upcoming summit,
we've actually gonna do
two or even three seminars.
And that that's gonna be online I guess. Right?
Basically no.
It's exactly.
As far  as the situation now,
there is a very good chance
that it would work out.
But of course, no promises.
It depends.
Actually, I keep forgetting that I'm here.
I'm here in California
and the situation here
is much different than it is
back in the Middle East.
So I'm very happy to hear that.
So tell me a little bit about you.
So you've had, I guess,
And it's about fifteen people each
for each two week program?
Fairly, 50 Palestinians, 50 Israelis
So you've had about 90 people
go through this thing so far.
Tell me a little bit about what
you've noticed about the the openness
that you're contributing or so,
you know, and I'm especially interested about
the continuation of what do you see
happening after the program
with these participants?
So basically,
we try to  find in terms of applicants
before the seminars,
before we accept the participants,
we try and find people.
Well, actually, like kind of sense of,
We could be entrepreneurs.
It doesn't have to be about I-tech.
It would be also about social impact stuff.
Of course, it could be also about
the other in the private sector
and also the public.
And also to work in the government one day.
If it's about the past 40 or in Israel,
we look to find the people who actually
want to be leaders one day.
And enough open minded to listen to ideas
and concepts that are
really not used to hear.
Right.
If it's in the West Bank or Israel.
So this is what we tried to find
before the seminars
and after the seminar.
So it really depends.
Those are you know, they're like alumni.
I really want to open start up.
So we actually help them
to get inside on top that.
The partnership with the accelerator,
which we have in [--]
and those were most, you know,
more thinking about getting into the I-tech.
We also nowadays try to find more
solutions, for also for them.
With Microsoft and Cisco
and other companies.
So it really depends about the situation.
Sure.
And now let's go a little bit higher and broader.
So this is now impacting,
you know, a few dozen of people
in dozens of people per summer.
How do you get this to scale?
So then how do you get the two
populations to have meaningful dialogue
and not just in small groups?
So the best and the easy thing for us
is basically to do, to create
more and more seminars.
Like now we do two seminars here.
Hopefully because
the demand can be easier.
We so far, the application is still open.
We got more than 400 applicants for it
and allowing for only 60 spots,
spots for the summer,
90, if we will actually be able to do
in the end free seminars
instead of only two.
And the demand is this.
So we definitely look to do more seminars
a year and in more concepts, for example,
each one of our partners, MIT
So now we're talking about actually
creating short a one week long seminar,
which will focus only about the
mobile app development and dialogue.
And also we talk about like doing another
concept, the four week long seminar
with Google, Google for startups,
with the office in Tel Aviv
of one week long seminar,
which actually focus about
dialogue and about entrepreneurship
to build up actually out to build startups
for those who are actually interested.
And then we can also find other thousands,
I guess, of applicants,
new applicants for the notes.
Now, we try to be candidates Tech2Peace
because, you know,
to take a vacation,
a two-week long vacation,
It's for many people to be tired
mainly for people who must work all
the year or in the summer vacation.
So.
That was my next question then.
These are everybody.
Everybody is busy and taking out two weeks
to form this dialogue and to be open
and to learn, even to learn new things,
even if it's disconnected
from the Israeli-Palestinian
conflict, is very demanding.
So how do you actually find this this
balance in this Win-Win situation where
people can balance it with their jobs?
Do you think there's room to do things
like this outside of a context of just
two week seminar, but throughout
the year and throughout the life?
So basically,
basically if I got your question right,
So definitely we can scale it much more.
We can do much more seminars.
We can create new concepts with similar
to our concept, basically, for example.
Now we collaborate with M.I.T. about a
We're hoping a MISTI
It's the internationally Department
of M.I.T. to basically help them
to a implement take the best
model in our place.
And the best location hopefully
going to be South Africa.
It gets dark in Judaism and local youth.
Yeah.
So, you know, for me, as the Jewish guy
for me, I just know it once.
It will also spread
a lot of places around the world.
For me, it's amazing example of decoding,
[--]
Yeah.
Even besides our region,
which we hopefully know in few years,
we're going to have Anglet and then after
that, a thousands of alumni,
that will to the government.
So you're you're definitely
seeing this grow and grow at scale.
And what do you see yourself continuing
to be a part of this full time over
the years or or these years of slowly
transitioning out and thinking about
other ventures that you want to do?
So it really depends.
Because throughout the year,
there are really really really
tough moments you know.
Three days before a seminar.
When we also do not get sometimes
the permits for the Palestinians
to enter Israel.
Wow.
And we don't know if the seminar actually
will take place as planned
with the same participants
or if it's it's about.
Also now with the Corona virus.
Of course, there's other NGO's
the budget today is really
suffering out of it.
So there are very, very intensive
and hard moments throughout the year.
But, you know, for me as a co-founder,
like, it's pretty hard
to fall asleep at night.
But on the other end.
When someone Palestinian or Israeli
in the last day of the seminar come to me,
you know, with the tear under the eye
and actually say to me, you know,
this experience actually changed my life.
This experience was so significant for me.
So it's so amazing.
I never thought that they're going to have
a Palestinian friend and or Palestinian.
I never thought that I gonna
have an Israeli friend.
Totally.
So those moments of people
and it's out of the topic
but it's a lot for Tech2Peace because
it's very emotional and very connecting.
I think to myself,
I do not wanna be out of it
Never.
But in the very hardly night.
That I cannot fall asleep.
Of course, I was thinking about.
Maybe it's too tough to do
something so, so crazy.
Because in this reality,
it's not something usual
to actually connect between Palestinian and Israelis.
In our region of course, it's something,
you know, in the United States.
So sometimes not nowadays, of course,
but in other times it's easier to bring
people from different backgrounds
in the Middle East with all the suffer,
with both sides, with many.
There are so many victims of both sides.
There's so many suffering,
so much [--]
so just bringing new people to be friends
with people that been never thought
they gonna be friends with
and not for only two week long seminars
You know, it's four months
and hopefully years after.
So those moments are the most significant.
This is why I hope to continue doing this.
Yeah.
I think that it's it's amazing because I
think it's very easy from far away to take
for granted this idea of bringing
together people for dialogue.
And, you know,
it's just peaceful dialogue.
On friends without the differences.
And I think that it's it's just hard
to grasp this idea that in the region
that where we're at in Israel
and the Middle East in general,
it's not that simple to get a Palestinian
and Israeli in the same room.
It's that simple, even logistically just
passing the borders,
putting aside all the personal differences
and then and the fact that  your
friends are gonna think you're crazy.
Your family's gonna disown you potentiall.
It's a problem.
And I think that being this
catalyst and fostering this annoying
happenings is something
that's really remarkable.
And I I've always said it to my family
and friends that I, unfortunately
have started losing faith.
And in the current system
of how we're trying to solve this.
And my personal
belief is that the only way this will be
solved is if my generation
if our generation can grow up
more open minded,
Visit the world
to talk to each other in a friendly way.
Start putting aside 5000 years
of differences, but focusing on the next
five thousand years
and potentially using technology to help
bridge that gap and the similarities.
I think that would be wonderful.
And first, I can't leave.
20 minutes are almost up
But Tomer, I have know three words
that best describe you.
Well,
it's a challenging to choose
It came by quickly.
Yes.
I would try.
Determined.
sometimes too much determined.
Honest
I try to be honest
to people as much as possible.
It's also very Israeli feel to
to be in that way.
Yeah.
I have other words,
Multi disciplinary.
Maybe a bit impulsive.
Maybe
I love it.
So I brought four different words.
I hope you were.
Very, very Israeli.
I  asked for three.
You give me four.
That's a plus.
Wonderful.
Tomer, toda raba.
Thank you for the inspiration.
And best of luck with Tech2Peace.
It sounds amazing.
Thank you so much, Michael.
Great.
Bye.